usted qué balance hace de este primer
año de mandato de castillo
bueno en efecto tiene un balance
positivo como negativo por nuevos lado
el lado negativo lo que fuimos decir es
que tengo castillo ha tenido un mal
manejo político en cuanto a las personas
a las que ha dado su cargo de confianza
con muchos errores que no estaban
preparadas para él
es necesario
dientes para esos funciones y en el lado
positivo podemos ver un crecimiento de
la economía bastante importante y
liderando en muchos casos la reacción de
administra las tomas en crecimientos que
van alrededor del 3% inversión pública e
incluso dio cuenta de la cobranza de
impuestos al sector energético que ha
sido con una mayor eficiencia
en las recaudaciones y en temas
macroeconómicos las cifras han sido muy
importantes y además se ha señalado de
que se aceptan o voces de mucha
discusión o de una difusión en los
medios locales
y pese a estos puntos positivos de su
mandato que usted indica cree que los
escándalos que rodean al mandatario
podrían acabar con su gobierno
con los escándalos que rodean al
mandatario podrían acabar con su
gobierno en la medida en que esto genere
una prueba concreta de momento mientras
acusación únicamente sea verbal castillo
va a poder sobrevivir gracias a un apoyo
que tiene con ciertas bancadas
parlamentarias o con una acción de estas
bancadas parlamentarias con la finalidad
de tener una permanencia en el gobierno
que le va a dar sostenibilidad y que lo
a brindar además una parte del
parlamento que sí apunta a la matanza
presidencial y que evidentemente ha
venido con estas acusaciones de momento
en el que se inicia la misión
presidencial o él es elegido presidente
por las autoridades peruanas
y ustedes ceo de una encuestadora el
país tiene está asumido en bastantes
protestas contra el gobierno se aprecia
un descenso en el apoyo a castillo entre
aquellos que le votaron hace un año o
mantiene por el momento sus apoyos
bueno de hecho tiene una alta votación
en contra y al ser entre un 65 y 70 por
ciento de esa población
esto hace que extenda evidentemente una
política en la cual va a tener que hacer
esfuerzos para aliar a que los problemas
principales como las tenemos
transmisibles y los alimentos con las
que también internaciones curso que
acaba de hacer adquisiciones esfuerzos
necesarios para frenar el alta y
disminuir y hablar